[Applause]
we've been told to carry on planning for
christmas
and wear a mask while doing the shopping
the prime minister says we're going to
have a better festive period than last
year
but with the emergence of the omicron
variant how confident can we be
well we still don't have enough data
about the new variant and until we do
the health secretary says it makes sense
to have some measures in place there's
reason to to think that it may be and i
stress the word may that this variant
may turn out to make our vaccines less
effective it may not we just don't know
enough so i do think people will take
this more seriously and i think that
will apply to public transport it will
apply in shops it will be a regulation
as it has been before but it's important
i think to to act in a proportionate way
and also in a temporary way i hope this
is
something that we can remove within
within weeks
face masks and other interventions are
designed to buy the government time
time to understand more about this
variant
and time to slow its spread as news of
more omicron cases emerge in the uk
the health security agency has warned
numbers of this variant are expected to
rise we're showing that we're worried
about it by the actions that have been
rapidly taken by the uk government but
also by other governments around the
world it has more mutations than
anything we've seen before and some of
those mutations are in areas of the
virus that would particularly affect the
immune response
the government rejects any criticism
that it has not acted quickly enough in
imposing targeted border controls it
says all restrictions must be
proportional
but with another case linked to travel
discovered today from someone who
arrived in the uk and has now left again
do these restrictions really go far
enough there are still some outstanding
issues around travel the government is
saying everyone has to have a pcr test
on day two when they arrive back in the
uk but they're not suggesting
pre-departure tests for people before
they board flights there's no advice for
people about traveling back from the
airport on public transport
in addition to transport and shops masks
will have to be worn in english schools
all pupils in year 7 and above
and visitors to sites are required to
wear face coverings in communal areas
the national education union welcomed
the recommendation saying in a statement
we think the department for education
should go further and encourage mask
wearing in secondary classrooms and also
plan investment to improve ventilation
and air filtration these steps can all
help reduce the spread of covert and
thereby reduce disruption to education
the speed of the spread of the omicron
variant has to be matched by the speed
of action to try and slow it down
so far all three cases have been linked
to overseas travel
there is no proof of community
transmission yet
if and when that happens
then a rethink on interventions
will be needed
joshi sky news